la cerise sur le gâteau c'est quoi
allomusic l'année dernière j'ai hanouna
tu pointes et explorer dia peut exciter
le rencontrer pour l'apprivoiser
ce gars là celle-là dakar une info mais
il en fait trois avec sa team il se
termine par un label baba
l'adoma c'est que la poule c
il est droit un ton coeur à gaza ont
cette folie et artix b
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est voir le monde quitte ici par 11
août dans son travail avec son patron et
tous les ans la forme à nîmes
quoi qu'est ce que eux c'est l'heure du
déjeuner
[Applaudissements]
tuvalu le gars dans un travail normal un
cocon l'un des impôts et écouter bon ben
j'ai fait le tour
bon bah enfin bon on va vous redresser
un petit peu sur toute la tva
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maxime vous avez été formidables trop
mignon voilà qu'il est mignon vous
voulez je vous dise qu'il a pour lui
c'est que tout passe meiway